[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est en fait quand elle
bilan elle veut dire chiant et puis ça
ressemble pas trop en faire non et 606
passé dans une ferme je sais je sais
gérer plus vite la prochaine fois
c'était juste à me servir
c'était la deuxième prise dit les
cadavres le manque de son c'est clair je
veux je veux qu'il y ait des litres de
sang haye
je vois
et tu crois que ça va partir sous les
sièges où il va falloir tout nettoyer la
vapeur avant ma mère reviennent
t'inquiète pas ça va allez fais moi
confiance c'est juste du sirop de maïs
on may be moi rien n'a très content il
faut vraiment eu cache le visage
d'accord lieberman était l'air d'avoir
17 ans c'est peut-être parce que j'ai
contente toi de cacher son visage un
temps
et aux bouffes quand t'es pas censés
nourrir ton équipe de tournage je n'ai
on a commandé des pizzas ligne de mire
il ya des bières au frère ali je crois
que si j'étais sous ce support très ce
tournage non on n'a pas bière et on
devrait pas faire ça moment venir fois
quand elle apprendra sardi vie
finalement on sent un tristement rien de
temps les filles les filles
mettez-y du vôtre vous verrez ça va être
génial et ce serait encore plus génial
si la tête de rihanna finissait dans la
cuve était
votre foot quand 16
la tête
[Musique]
je veux la vérité est-elle déformé par
les prismes à travers lesquelles nous
l'observons d'ailleurs y at il une
vérité quand on est un journaliste
il faut toujours se poser cette question
fondamentale savoir laisser une place
aux doutes car c'est ce doute qui vous
fera avancer dans votre histoire creuser
toujours au plus profond
d'accord à quito
les ponts cachée de la ville de marshall
[Musique]
allez rallye
on cache et à l'exposé d'une demi heure
et une ligne de chemin de fer
je te signale d'abord le projet pour
faire grève qui va brûler les doigts
d'en venir car je ne suis pas un sujet
mois au moins ton projet c'est juste une
excuse pour faire un film d'horreur et
alors c'est dix fois plus intéressant
est dix fois plus de locaux sinon j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt sympa moi hier rihanna
et moi quand on aura fini la fac on ira
à hollywood les nouveaux brad et
angelina ça lui allait mais je suis très
sérieux c'est queen il faut que je que
je lui rende les caméras le matériel du
doigt les clés ça te dérange si je
l'invite à la fête ce soir hors de
question trop vieux et trop bizarre
allez il nous a beaucoup aidés non ils
vous ayez des toits érié moi tu vois je
suis pas si stupide pour m'inscrire un
cours des bises de journalisme et puis
franchement qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
vrai prix faisant partie du matériel
c'est moi qui donne la sécu et des
chutes toute la soirée oh oui tu l'as
fait merveille
[Musique]
salut ça va c'est par là
on pouvait plus on a refait la scène au
moins trente fois on a dû finir vers
minuit sans compter qu'on a dû rester
deux heures de plus pour nettoyer le
fossan des sièges
mais bon merci quand même et il ya une
fête ce soir ça va être cool tu peux
passer si tu veux j'ai du travail
d'accord mais on va finir tard les
parents de brianna et didier sont partis
pour le week-end alors elle s'est
organisé une petite fête d'anniversaire
brianna brianna baker ouais c'est chez
elle que ça se passait je verrai way
queen
tu pourras jeter un oeil aux archives de
la chaîne locale histoire de voir s'ils
ont quelque chose sur arland il des
choses que je pourrais inséré au film
qui ça arlene deal le le gars le gars
sur qui je fais mon film tu sais parce
que c'est une histoire vraie ouais c'est
réellement arrivé et quand ça s'est
passé il ya à peu près deux ans aux
seniors je t'enverrai la der garde mais
c'est comme ça
quinn où est passé le matériel tu dois
faire une liste de l'équipement que tu
prends avant de sortir des locaux et tu
le sais ah c'est du joli cas c'est du
joli jeter un oeil jeta rails des
prévenus
alors la doite offrir quoi pour ton
anniversaire ce qui va m'offrir ou ce
que je les deux parce que je veux c'est
les entrées pour concert des schnitzels
d'accord et lui il va t'offrir quoi
sûrement un vibromasseur
nantes est furieuse à arette
non c'est la triste vérité mon copain
est terriblement romantique pas vrai
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a atteint soeur
ça j'en sais rien
elle doit avoir ses règles
[Musique]
la police a confirmé le multiple
homicide qui a eu lieu ici
mais elle n'a évoqué aucun mobile ou
explication possible plus de la rue
cette maison ressemble à n'importe quel
autre mais à l'intérieur il n'en est
rien les agents de police sont dans
cette maison depuis 48 heures ils y ont
découvert une famille de 4 personnes
assassinées
ils ont été appelés sur les lieux lundi
aux alentours de 3h30 du matin
alertés par un appel de suicide il qu'il
eut des mots furie
les policiers sont maintenant partis et
les questions subsistent qu est il
exactement arrivé et pourquoi créer sa
ford en direct pour wplm 13
alors
ouais j'ai quelque chose dans une heure
ça je m'en fous tu attendras une heure
et détend toi
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
douglas la cour
fort bien m
roulement de tambour
génial maintenant rihanna doit
s'entraîner
mike leake d'orgasme
je croyais que j'avais avec un ciel
il ya quatre types d'orgasme n'y fait
tu savais pas ça si bien sûr tu ne sais
pas ça au milieu nous avons l'orgasme
positif
oui
[Musique]
cuisine
le médiatique et enfin nous avons
l'orgasme subi
l'approché merde
et merde
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites les enfants on
parle on parle pas la bouche pleine
ça devrait toujours aussi drôle à ce que
je vois un net
j'essaie de m'amuser un peu pourquoi web
rihanna je sais pas mais elle est furax
qu'est ce que tu lui encore fait je lui
ai offert un vibromasseur c'est tout
mais ce qu'elle sait pas c'est que je
les réserve une autre surprise dit vous
m'aider à la retrouver mais oui alors la
chercher on va la trouver
[Musique]
soit on a mis du temps qu'est ce que
c'est
les vestiaires tu lâches
comme d'habitude la petite baker pour
l'avoir essayé d'en savoir un peu plus
je suis sur le coup fait encore un
effort
[Musique]
il ya les sites moi seul concert auquel
tu as été vas-y attend voir ses
comparses le meilleur film d'horreur de
l'histoire et son le cercle t pas devenu
fou devant la télé lequel trop de prison
dont un peu de ma mère fait relire ses
prix mais si ça les noms ficelles les
enfants dont sa mère et ça c'est affreux
qui leur offre tu deviens tu as mais je
n'arrive pas en un ta mère est cool
ta mère est génial pourquoi tu voudrais
qu non ta mère est trop cool
qu'est ce qui aurait de si terrible ils
organisaient une fête pour nous elle
n'est pas en courant pour cette fête je
te signal
salut ça va queen c'est cool que tu vas
dire salut salut s'ils quittent ces gens
ça c'est pour toi joyeux anniversaire
si gentil et ouvre le monde entier moi
ça
waouh cool un lecteur blu ray un peu
exagéré de la porte quelqu'un que je
connais à peine c'est pas grand chose
j'ai une grosse réduction à cause de mon
boulot ainsi p c'est fascinant
et queen tu veux une bière il ya un
baril à côté de la piscine
non
et
quoi tu le connais d'où déjà ce gars oui
ils travaillaient avec moi mes cassettes
vidéo et là il travaille pour la télé
locale
il est cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et queen tu t'en vas
ouais je me sens pas trop à ma place
c'est comme est de retour dans ce lycée
de merde tu viens oui j'arrive tout de
suite ok tiens j'ai failli oublier
j'ai des images darlene deal je t'ai mis
ça sur une clé usb assez génial merci
queen attends tu crois que tu crois que
tu pourrais parler de moi aux gens de
chez nous tu travailles cette chaîne
pour i way va pas travailler la bague
ben j'adorerais y travailler tu vois je
veux évoluer j'en ai marre de regarder
des vidéos je veux les faire tu sais ce
que je fais là bas au juste non pas
vraiment je fais rien de créatif chez
archiv des images vieille de 20 ans le
cul vissé sur une chaise à regarder dans
le vide
parlons un peu de ton projet je vais
aborder dr des choses qu'on a oublié
dans notre communauté et en faire un
film
un film un film sur quoi maintenant que
tu demandes ça dérange raciste
interviewé c'est sûr
alors la dyle je veux pas rendre un
travail débit sur le folklore local les
ponts et toutes ces conneries
non ça c'est une histoire intéressante
et tu te souviens tu disais que ça avait
changé la communauté c'est le sujet du
devoir alors et en plus c'est assez cool
non ça n'a rien de cool julian c'était
une tragédie et je n'ai jamais dit que
ça avait changé la communauté j'ai dit
que ça va changer la vie des gens c'est
tout désolé j'ai cru que tu pourrais
m'aider avec ça tu sais c'est ce que
font les parents général au fait tu te
souviens de caen c'est d'arriver tout ça
je m'en souviens bien sûr senate je dois
y aller
c'est alors on en reparlera plus tard
ouais si tu veux aller donc téléphone
[Musique]
papa
qu'est ce que t'en dit et n'a pas une
meilleure prise non pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui va pas eh ben c'est ton
cadrage l'image tremble elle tremble
c'est filmé caméra à l'épaule ça ça
donne de la force à la scène
les réalisateurs vois ça comme ça alors
pour le commun des mortels ça donne la
nausée et c'est tout je crois que je
vais couper la scène où elle s'habille
j'ai un doute avec la nuit dit et je
sais pas si ça va bien passé c'est ce
qui inquiète si la nudité va bien passé
ouais ouais je veux dire tu rigoles et
non mais il ya du sang partout
ouais c'est la fête de l'émetteur c'est
juste un film adam milton d'halluciner
quand elle verra raid et puis c'est mon
problème ça ok c'est toi qui vois ouais
tu m'as dit
oui
hélas
une foule matériel que tu as emprunté
quinn
non réf
n'importe quoi regardez moi ces fourmis
mais qu'est ce que tu fous ici un va
saccager tout mon installation c'est un
vrai bordel ici c'est un désastre
félicitations je vais pas nettoyer ça
couine
voilà c'est tout je compte rien faire
d'autre mais qu'est ce que tu fous ici
dans quel état est la salle des archives
ramasse moi toutes ces saloperies t'as
intérêt à organiser et je veux tout le
matériel que tu as emprunté
j'ai jamais vu ça c'est un vrai bordel
c'est pas croyable il ya même des mégots
de cigarettes damon brad smith
il a été adopté
visiblement les vrais parents darlene
sont morts quand il avait 4 ans il est
né à new york
il est passé d'une famille d'accueil à
une autre jusqu'à ce qu'il soit adopté
par la famille dit il c'est courant chez
les familles pauvres histoire de toucher
des allocations way son vrai nom et
harlan prime ce descendant du mystérieux
louis leprince
le mystérieux qui jouit le prince n'a
jamais entendu parler oui c'est pour ça
qu'il est mystérieux attend revient en
arrière
ouais c'est la firme qui est sûre
endersen road près de ça soude
tu sais celle qui est caché par les
armes tu vois de laquelle je parle pas
vrai ouais peut-être bien ouais quoi on
va l'avoir
[Musique]
il me semble que ma mère m'a dit qu'un
des frères thil avait hérité de la
maison après les meurtres
si c'est bien la maison de la photo
alors elle appartient aux tirs c'est pas
elle m'a dit qu'il avait détruit pour
vendre le terrain
[Musique]
vous
la voilà
tu avais raison c'est la même maison
pourquoi est ce que ma mère m'a menti
on aurait pu tourner mon film ici
on me regarde c'est la carla n'a tué sa
soeur sa soeur adoptive c'est pas pareil
bon on s'en va cet endroit commence à me
[ __ ] la trouille
on a qu'à jeter un coup d'oeil
et oh ya quelqu'un chez parce qu'on fait
là c'est peut-être pas une bonne idée
ces images montées très essentielle au
projet
waouh la salle de bain
c'est là qu'il a tué sa mère
ah les gens qu'on parte julian really
j'ai presque fini
attends tendance ah oui qu'est ce que
c'est je crois que ça vient d'eux
c'est une chambre de bébé regarde mais
aucun rapport ne mentionne un bébé
au début ça
[Musique]
c'est vraiment glauque et ça va être
super pour la vidéo écoute julian je
pense qu'on devrait y aller enfin bon on
fait juste des recherches pour notre
projet n'insiste pas julian madame
miller je suis vraiment désolé d'accord
y est tu peux y aller julian rentrera
avec moi à peine mois plus tard entendu
tu n'a rien à faire ici et pourquoi
savoir ce que c'est une propriété privée
ça va maman on n'a rien volé arrête on
fait juste des recherches et alors
qu'est ce qui te fait croire que tu au
dessus des lois tu n'a rien à faire là
comment tu as su qu'on était là
géolocalisé ton portable tu as fait quoi
et depuis quand tu sais faire ça écoute
jolie en tant que tu vis aux montois
tués sous ma responsabilité ce qui veut
dire que j'ai le droit de savoir où tu
es pourquoi donc tu puisses nous [ __ ]
la trouille à moi et à ma copine pour
que je puisse te protéger tu n'as pas à
me protéger maman je suis assez grand
pour faire tout seul
la famille dit il a vécu des choses
horribles des choses qui ont tristement
marqué l'histoire de cette ville et
personne n'a envie d'aller fouiller dans
le passé
personne n'a envie de revivre ces choses
je te conseille de trouver un autre
sujet pour ton projet est-ce que c'est
clair
[Musique]
ce mr
il
[Musique]
c'est qui ça c'est le mystérieux louis
leprince l'arrière arrière grand père
bardet selon de nombreux historiens
il serait l'un des inventeurs du cinéma
je croyais que c'était thomas edison
c'est ce que je croyais aussi et tu dis
que c'est un parent darlene oui c'est ce
que j'ai lu regarde c'est une image du
jardin de rugby d'après ce site c'est le
premier film qu'on a tourné le premier
film de l'histoire c'est d'un nom tu as
trouvé quelque chose sur le bébé rien du
tout on en parle nulle part et j'ai
trouvé que cette photo de la famille
elle a l'air enceinte sur la photo nous
on dirait effectivement et le certificat
de naissance
si la soeur bahreïn avait un bébé il
doit y en avoir une trace administrative
regarde c'est rob zombie
à aller faire ça dans un hôtel mais
c'est prévu le shining 'on sait soir mon
vieux non tu rigoles vous allez sécher
les cours
oui on se fait la malle on va dans un
hôtel ans pour la gueule et on s'endort
instant le sternum je ne savais pas si
romantique
en parlant de secret il faut que vous
voyez ce qu'on a trouvé sur adil
j'imagine que c'est totalement facile
ouais regarde c'est pour toi j'ai été
prise dans la ferme de 10 je crois que
c'est là bas qu'on devrait aller tourner
ses seins spielberg attend c'est toi qui
as mon portable non à prendre bien
attaquer tapis merci
[Musique]
alors oui c'est toi qui es mon téléphone
on dirait un tu l'as trouvé vous ici et
ici c'est ou à la maison
ouais
[Musique]
tu aimes ça dans le fond quoi aller
jusqu'au bout des choses
ouais pas toi c'est pas bien
salut queen qu'est ce que tu fous là
perds mon téléphone tu te souviens
ça va
ouais
ok super merci à la prochaine
tu veux entrer et louer un film
je devrai appris je te recommande un dvd
non c'est gentil on n'a pas les mêmes
goûts en matière de films je te rappelle
ah ouais c'est vrai
pour devenir
quoi ma
quoi à tout à l'heure
salut
you ça va comme tu veux
au fait vous dit tu as déjà entendu
parler d'un certain louis leprince
ouais bien sûr tu as déjà bien de ses
films fascine il n'a fait que 3 mai
j'appellerai passe à des films ces
oeuvres ne dure que quelques secondes
on doit en avoir des copies quelque part
via paris 6 et noir mat sans rio il faut
que j'y aille t'as vu mais ils sont
intéressants c'est fini pas autant que
ne veulent aller journal quoi qu'elle
les jambes et y'a que les gens bien
informés qui connaît cette légende selon
laquelle louis leprince serait le diable
le diable mais lloris est réfléchie
louis lucifer le prince des ténèbres
on aura tout entendu attend ce sera
l'incarnation du mal à cause de son nom
un nom c'est très révélateur
réfléchissez l'eau ici faire dans les
portes de l'enfer
john milton dans l'avocat du diable
darryl van horne dans les sorcières
d'eastwick tous des internationaux
diable oui mais ce sont des personnages
de cinéma c'est de la fiction est une
légende à ton avis si loin
je
dis moi tu connais la superstition qu'il
est une photo volée une partie de ton
âme samedi quelque chose c'est bien
certaines personnes y croient dur comme
fer
est ce cher louis leprince a figé cette
croyance dans ses films il a réussi à
capturer ce qui semble être une vraie
personne je te parle pas d'un prix figé
comme une photographie mais des quelque
chose qui bouge comme une entité de l'au
delà
selon la légende louis le prince aurait
volé non seulement une partie de l'âme
mais l'âme tout entière attend et quels
rapports c'est avec le reste du monde
j'y viens louis leprince avait un fils
il s'appelait adolphe c'était son vrai
nom figure toi parfait pour mon histoire
mais bref
adolphe était dans son premier film le
jardin de rambo la légende dit que louis
aurait tourné ce film afin de folie
l'âme de son fils et de la remplacer par
la sienne et il faut croire que son âme
était sombre
selon la légende il aurait transmis ce
mal à toute sa descendance douanes
enfants posséder à chaque génération
une malédiction transmise de père en
fils plus puissante et maléfique à
chaque fois
on dirait que tu viens de l'inventer
non si tu ne crois pas tu peux chercher
tout et sur internet
si c'est sur internet ça doit être vrai
tu sais quoi je vais trouver le film et
tu verras que je me fous pas de toi
tiens il ya le jardin de rangdet dedans
regardez le ah et au fait tous ceux qui
apparaissent à l'image sont décédés ça
monte à plus de 100 ans évidemment
qu'ils sont décédées n'ont ils sont
morts après avoir joué dans le film
[Musique]
non
note d'accor qui sait il n'ya pas de
caméra dans ma chambre chemin
[Musique]
quoi c'est tout ouais je t'avais dit que
c'était quoi
et tous ces gens sont morts après avoir
tourné ce film
ouais et c'est ce qui fait la légende de
ce film au fait tu savais carriére
arrière arrière petit fils de la
princesse letizia marshall ouais ouais
je sais c'est pour ça que je m'intéresse
à lui j'ai un exposé vidéo à rendre à
temps un exposé sur arles and deal pour
tes cours ouais c'est vraiment clokey
j'espère t'avoir été utile c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire je sais pourquoi
il a tué toute sa famille maintenant ils
étaient possédés
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu fous là tu as lu
si nous quoi tu fais six mois fallait
que je te parle
qu'est-ce que tu est envisagée j'ai eu
brianna la caméra et dans sa chambre on
sache en forme actuellement en service
quelques jours de service je voudrais
accéder aux archives de la police pour
la violation de domicile je peux
sûrement juste mais quand il ya une
fraction c'est plus compliqué deux mois
ce que te filmer dans la chambre je
verrai ce que je peux faire
non je parle pas de mon casier là il me
faut quelque chose dans le dossier
darlène dit
qu'est ce que tu sais sur lui
je sais que la police a réquisitionné un
tas de cassettes vidéo dans sa ferme
qu'est ce que tu veut [ __ ] avec ça ça
te regarde pas si ça me regarde
arland il couché tout sur vidéo je crois
y compris sa soeur je suis sûr qu'elle
doit être à poil dans ses films j'ai un
autre client qui voudraient voir ces
images mais un client tadic lee antoine
pourquoi tu penses que tu es le seul
tordus en ville ou quoi 1 tu es
complètement folle tu sais comme moi tu
veux alors je te donne pas les images de
la fille quand tu sais de me forcer la
main petits cons d'un g7 motivé avec
tout ce que je sais sur toi je pourrais
te faire plonger
et moi donc
bon je pense qu'on va devoir régler ça à
la dure l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
dépêche-toi wayana et demie aller
brianna fait rempart bébé tu viens faut
qu'on y aille
rihanna rihanna a les gestes rouge
mais qu'est ce que tu fais le faut qu'on
y aille
[Musique]
la maca
oui
je suis désolé d'être en retard crois
moi écoute je me ferais pardonner ses
preuves tu sais je suis sûr qu'on a
juste raté la première partie alors on
s'en fout stoppé par mois les dix mois
quelque chose bruit
je commence à me faire peur mais bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est quoi ça
prix qu'est ce qui t'arrive merde c'est
quoi
soir qui a déjà commencé à voir
on m'a pété les pennois
elle a yant le lieutenant votre foi
vous vouliez me voir lieutenant oui
franck acier vous est ce que vous
connaissez les jeunes de franklyn les
adolescents qui vont nous laisser
quelques temps pourquoi vous connaissez
en attendant de st qu'est ce qui lui
arrive eh bien ça mais rappelez il n'est
pas rentré chez lui hier soir
ce qui m'étonne c'est qu'elle elle soit
rentrer chez elle hier soir elle était
au bar avec encline cycle ap le thème en
rentrant chez vous ou passer par le
lycée voyez ce que ses amis en dise
c'est probablement rien mais je veux que
vous y alliez ce sera tous les tenants
ce sera tout franck vous voulez pas non
plus que j'ai d'une vieille dame a
traversé la rue tant que j'y suis ce
n'est peut-être pas une mauvaise idée
d'après ce qu'on dit ça ne ferait pas de
mal à votre réputation
ça prendrait combien de temps à peu près
un quart d'heure
on travail et encore du wes est pour ça
qu on voudrait ton avis
vous voulez que je vous notre
non pas que tu ne t'es pas
moi pourquoi est ce qu'il veut me parler
comment ça va bien
comment tu t'appelles
diddy diddy baker airbus dit oui un peu
tu n'as aucune raison de s'inquiéter
je suis l'agent lion's je veux juste
poser quelques questions entendu il va
rien t'arriver
j'espère bien je vois vraiment pas ce
que j'aurais fait de mal je parie que tu
es une fille sage toi je suis une fille
responsable si c'est ce que vous voulez
dire
et là tu vas me dire que tu chantes dans
l'accord est justement oui j les mêmes
parce que monsieur carpenter et qu'il
dirige toujours la chorale non gt gt
dans la chorale massive gt gt baryton
e
comment comment tu connais nathan
brannen nathan sort avec massa et toi
est-ce que tu tu sors avec quelqu'un non
alors ça c'est vraiment du gâchis
qu'est ce que ça a été bizarre pourquoi
qu'est ce qui t'a demandé là t'es pas
rentré hier soir sa mère est super
inquiète heures ça n'a rien de bizarre
c'est la manière dont il l'a dit tu le
dis quoi qu'il est allé au concert des
chats ni tigers avec rihanna tu le lui a
dit oui bien sûr sinon sa mère va penser
qu'il est mort au fond d'un fossé
je suis inquiète aussi et s'il est
arrivé quelque chose à brianna
maintenant on arrête
[Musique]
on
ouais oui d'accord je prends les images
de la chambre mais je les veux tout de
suite c'est tout ce que je peux faire je
te 2 500 $ si je les trouve pas d'accord
je veux pas de ton fric tu entends j'ai
dit que j'ai serré merde c'est clair
alors deux mois ces vidéos
[Musique]
ça va julian laisse tomber hockey non
écoute on peut le faire d'accord mais
aujourd'hui on n'a plus le temps de
chercher ce qui est arrivé aux bébés
l'exposé pour aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas assez poussé nos
recherches faut continuer l'exposé est
censé commencer dans une demi heure à
qui tu veux parler un nouveu tu qu'on
aille crise sa forme qui tue c'est celui
des infos le journaliste on a peut-être
temps que se rendre au studio allait
bien et 10 heures de questions il
faudrait que tu expliques ça madame
l'italie s'il te plaît non attends est
ta voiture
[Musique]
je viens voir chris sa ford l'un de vos
journalistes merci jean thriller cette
partie
[Musique]
je veux parler à chris sa forte s'il
vous plaît oui non excusez-moi je veux
parler à chris sa ford
oui je voudrais parler à qui sa ford
vous êtes crise à ford désolé j'ai dû me
tromper numéro
salut bonjour
qu'est ce que tu fais là ma soeur n'est
toujours pas rentré vous m'avez dit de
vous contacter s'il y avait quelque
chose de bizarre
bien sûr ouais alors je peux entrer oui
bien sûr
vous vivez seul là maintenant oui
divorcé e écoute donc tu dis que tu as
her il n'est pas rentré à la maison hier
soir oui je voulais déjà dit elle est
allée à un concert avec son petit copain
mais ils devaient rentrer immédiatement
après peut-être qu'ils sont encore en
virée mais je crois qu'elle mourrait
prévenu je comprends que tu dois être
inquiète je peux téléphoner au no
hôpitaux ou à la brigade routière est
sûr d'avoir eu des accidents des
arrestations ce genre de choses merci là
je suis sûr qu'il va bien
pas tant
agent lion's non l'appelle mon frère
frank
je sais que vous observez queen me l'a
dit quoi qu'est ce que tu as dit que
vous me relis pied dans les vestiaires
et que vous le payez pour s'annoncer
n'importe quoi quinn dépeint un petit
délinquant lunatique et vous savez
franck ça me plaît de savoir que vous me
regardez combien vous le payez jeu je ne
vois pas de quoi tu page
je ne le payent parfois y en a mais je
ne dirai rien à personne
je ne vois toujours pas de quoi tu
parles selon lui vous vouliez me voir
dans ma chambre et vous alliez lui
donner plusieurs cassettes en échange
vous lui avez donné ses cassettes vidéo
n'ont rien à voir avec toi écoute je
vais chercher environ n'avaient rien de
plus fort j'ai de l'eau la classe
salut
tu sais pas où est julian j'ai tout le
matériel que vous vouliez quel matériel
ben pour votre projet
les nouvelles prises il m'a dit de le
déposer ici
il m'a dit qu'il te faisais confiance
qui me faisait confiance
ouais il m'a dit que tu surveillerait le
matériel jusqu'à son retour alors comme
ça vous voulez filmé dans la ferme des
deals tu pourrais m'aider faut que je
retourne travailler
[Musique]
y'a pas grand chose tu as vu ça nous
prendra une minute mais coûte tu ne
devrait pas être ici
tu sais ça pourrait me causer pas mal
dont il faut que tu partes dégâts
ce sera mon petit secret
j'ai envie de voir comment vous faites
le
faites comme si vous étiez tout seul
athènes
vous aimez regarder à moins de regarder
maintenant
vous avez besoin de souligner non ouais
je sais il m'a dit qu'il avait besoin du
trépied je pense que j'ai de pouvoir
porter tout ça désolé il te faut aussi
ce câble peut l'attraper
je vais essayer
chris sa forte est coupée et si julian
miller je voudrais l'interviewer à
propos de sa carrière de journaliste
oui oui vous dites que je peux le
trouver ou un monsieur
[Musique]
les coupes
tout
depuis
que de regarder sur un écran
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu vas où oui
ouais
pour
alors elle rentre à la maison elle fait
ce que je lui dit de faire
quoi pourquoi pardon je viens de lui
dire de s'en aller lui dit pas de s'en
aller d'accord je veux qu'à reste ici
non tu vas rester là a dû faire un noeud
avec les couilles tu m'auras pas donné
les potters cassette que je t'ai demandé
écoute j'ai été sept d'accord elles et
elles sont juste là je suis allé les
chercher hier soir
alors dis lui de rester longtemps ça les
cassettes ça bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux pas te forcer à part chez soi je
suis pas j'ai des boutons
je me sentais perdue enfin tu veux
[Musique]
juste je sais faire
et s'il fait ça
[Musique]
excusez moi je cherche la réception
bourré
d'accord
[Musique]
mais c'est sa ford
je je suis julian miller je peux
m'asseoir
vous êtes l'un de ces infirmiers
bénévoles
non non non ont fait un projet pour
l'école et je voudrais m'entretenir avec
vous sur l'un de vos reportages jeu je
pensais que vous pourriez me donner des
informations sur eux sur harlan deeley
harley deal 1994
oui c'est ça 1994
ça a été mon dernier grand reportage
avec mon amie on a fait pas mal de
recherches mais on n'a rien réussi à
trouver sur le baby
comment savez vous qu'il y avait un bébé
on a enquêté vous savez j'ai essayé d'en
savoir plus sur cette histoire oui c'est
une grande histoire à vrai dire je suis
allé au fond de cette affaire moi aussi
et qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert
demandez à n'importe qui pour quoi ce
massacre s'est produit
personne ne vous le dira à personne ne
le sait aucun mobile
c'est ce que la police a dit arland il
devait être mentalement instable mais
quelque chose a déclenché ces meurtres
quelque chose ou quelqu'un est ce
quelqu'un c'est le bébé continuer
et bien d'après ce que j'ai découvert
les parents voulaient donner le bébé en
adoption
ce n'était pas du goût d'un harlan bien
sûr on peut difficilement en vouloir aux
parents si vous découvriez que votre
fils est votre fille avait des relations
vous auriez fait la même chose non
attendez qu est ce que vous avez dit
harlem dieu inviolée chasseurs sa soeur
adoptive
elle est tombée enceinte les parents ne
voulaient pas que ça se sache
ils ont décidé de faire adopter un bébé
alors harlan les a tuées qu'est ce qui
est arrivé aux baby
c'est là où je me suis arrêtée dans mes
recherches j'ai bien cherché à savoir
mais j'ai essayé mais quelqu'un a la
chance d'adoption a dit qu'un un des
agents de police présents sur les lieux
avait recueilli un bébé
et sept agents présents sur les lieux
vous vous avez découvert qui c'était oui
une femme très gentille je veux noir je
vais vous voyez souvent en ville mais
leurs 1000 r oui miller
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai non c'est pas vrai les
idées ou météo la mémoire tout de suite
rallye tu vas me croire j'ai découvert
car l'être
il faut que c'est peut-être ma mère n'a
jamais parlé mais on est peut-être par
an et je il faut absolument que tu me
rappelles tu entends c'est pas vrai
maman
or
non
[Musique]
queen queen
qu'est-ce que
quoi se porter
oh
temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
jours
t'as aucune raison d'être triste ceci
est la destinée et toi aussi tu en fais
partie il a besoin de toi comme jay
[Musique]
julien dumond non quoi d'neuf lieutenant
qui êtes vous one
il est occupé rappeler plus tard qui est
de l'appareil la vérité je ne sais pas
de quoi vous parlez
laissez moi parler à mon fils
[Musique]
on sera patient
vie
m
[Musique]
des ménages
à
[Musique]
on
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
les voitures fuient
espèce de ça
[Musique]
dp
j'ai mal à la tête
[Musique]
tu peux marcher oui il faut qu'on y
aille
[Musique]
e
tous ces corps
dans le cher et inutile il n'y a plus
rien à en tirer
[Musique]
oui
julien
julian
si on voit passer ma mère non peuvent
tout marquage toi
julian
[Musique]
du lien
non
centrale un cadavre dans la ferme des
deals sûrement à nos missiles tombent
clo
sortait de vous est très avancé jusqu'à
ce que je vois
je
[Musique]
il
non non
notre espèce d'enfoiré
[Musique]
[Rires]
la police de laval enquête sur un
multiple homicide qui est un crime en
tout point similaire au meurtre triste
tu les uns a perpétré par la ville selon
le rapport de police
trois personnes ont été tuées et
plusieurs autres blessées dont le
lieutenant albi l'heure de la police de
marshall je cherchais quelque chose à
manger comme tu fais quelque chose
notre appel d'urgence et a découvert
deux autres victimes pour le moment les
autorités
tu pourrais existait un lien entre les
deux offices en direct de marshall g13
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]